[Music]
welcome back so we've been talking about
the fast Fourier transform and how you
can use this to compute the Fourier
transform on vectors of data and you can
use this to denoise data analyze data
also to approximate the derivatives of
data numerically and today we're going
to talk about how to use the FFT to
solve the FFT to solve partial
differential equations FFT for PDEs okay
and we're going to do this numerically
and so what I'm going to walk through
here are a couple of examples the heat
equation the one-way wave equation and
burgers equation and we're gonna see how
we can code up and simulate these
partial differential equations using the
fast Fourier transform to approximate
the derivatives okay so we're gonna
start with the heat equation and I just
want to remind you the heat equation is
U T equals alpha squared u xx this is
the one-dimensional heat equation where
u is a temperature T as time and X space
so maybe I'll write that out U is a
function of X and T and I'll just label
these this is my temperature X is space
a spatial variable and T is time and
what we're going to do is we're going to
Fourier transform this so we're gonna
take the FFT and we're gonna get some U
hat of now Kappa and time so this is
still a function of time but now Kappa
is a spatial a spatial frequency or a
wave number sometimes I call this Omega
sometimes I call it Kappa but I try to
remember to use Kappa when I'm doing the
Fourier transform with respect to X so
here before you transforming the X
variable space and instead we're
replacing X with these spatial wave
numbers Kappa okay and the key
observation here is that if I have
derivatives like u X or u X X then when
we Fourier transform these
what we get is this UX derivative
becomes the complex number I times Kappa
times u hat if I take another derivative
that's just I squared Kappa squared u
hat which is minus Kappa squared u hat
so it's easy to compute derivatives in
space in this case just by Fourier
transforming and multiplying by by Kappa
or Kappa squared okay now this is we've
already seen this before but when we do
this with the fast Fourier transform
now this u hat is a vector of Fourier
coefficients u would be a vector of data
in each spatial location and u hat is a
vector of Fourier coefficients and Kappa
and Kappa squared are vectors of
frequencies so now what we get is
something like minus Kappa one squared u
hat one the first component of U hat
Kappa 2 squared u 2 hat and so on and so
forth down to Kappa n squared u and hat
the nth component so this is again a
vector of the product of Kappa squared
times times u hat and once you take this
vector and inverse Fourier transform you
would recover in this case the second
derivative of U ok so that's what we're
gonna do we're going to use this kind of
formulation to approximate first and
second derivatives and we're gonna use
that to solve this PDE in matlab using
using OD 45 and we'll use OD e int in in
python okay so will some of it in matlab
and in Python and here I'm just gonna
Fourier transform the equations and what
we get is u hat this is still a function
of time so I can still take its time
derivative so u hat derivative equals
minus alpha squared Kappa squared u hat
ok and the thing to remember here is
that u hat is a function of Kappa and
time so for every single Kappa there's a
discrete set of n Kappas for each of
these Kappas
this is just an ordinary differential
equation in U hat at that particular
kappa okay this is just an ordinary
differential equation u hat dot equals
some constant times u hat and we know
the solution of that it's you know e to
the lambda T where this is this is
lambda and so we can solve this this
this differential equation using OD a 45
or we could even do this analytically
and so that's going to be really useful
okay so this is essentially a decoupled
so that's also really nice is that for
every Kappa this is a single
one-dimensional OD II so I get n OD es
so I have n decoupled OD es one for each
each of these Kappas okay so for each of
these Kappa J's let's say I have one
ordinary differential equation I have to
solve okay good so what we're gonna do
is we're going to code this up and we're
going to to simulate this essentially
using just a regular or OD e solver
using the fast Fourier transform to
approximate the derivative and then
we're gonna try this out for the one-way
wave equation and also for burgers
equation okay so let's let's start that
out alright so here is the FFT solution
to the heat equation in Python okay
and I'm gonna point out that the
majority of this code is actually
initializing the domain and the problem
a very it's actually really simple to
simulate this and then a lot of it is
for plotting so I'll just walk you
through this whole code here the first
thing we're going to do is we're
defining the the domain that we're gonna
solve this PDE over and I should point
out that we are going to simulate an
initial temperature distribution in this
top hat like before where it starts out
at zero temperature it goes up to one
and then back down to zero and we know
that if we have all this in time what's
going to happen is that the high
frequency corners are going to diffuse
first we're going to get kind of this
rapid diffusion of the
and then as time goes on you're gonna
get this kind of Gaussian diffusion of
this of this solution so that's what we
expect from the analytic solution here
we're going to code it up in the using
the fast Fourier transform okay so our
domain goes is a domain of length 100
that goes from minus 50 to 50 so minus
50 to 50 we're gonna have a thousand
data points in that domain so that'll
set up a particular Delta X here I'm
gonna define my kappa vector so this
vector of frequencies in kappa from low
frequency to high frequency is all
stacked into this kappa vector and this
is actually kind of nice in matlab this
would be kind of two lines of code in in
python you just use this numpy fft fft
freak and it'll give you this kappa
vector okay and then we're going to
create our initial conditions here so we
have an initial condition that looks
like this top hat function and we're
going to Fourier transform that initial
condition to get u naught hat okay so
remember the whole game that we're
playing here is we're taking our PDE
we're gonna take our initial condition
we're gonna Fourier transform everything
and we're gonna simulate the system in
the Fourier transform domain so we're
gonna we're gonna start with u hat not
our initial conditions Fourier
coefficients and we're gonna integrate
that in time using an Eau de integrator
some Runge Kutta integrator and we're
gonna get a times of evolution of U hat
and then we can inverse Fourier
transform and find what our original
temperature distribution was in both
space and in time okay so here we're
just taking our initial condition and
Fourier transforming it okay good
here's a little line to handle kind of
complex numbers but this is the the key
point here is that we're going to take
this this right-hand side function that
is the right-hand side of our vector
field in U hat and we're going to
simulate that using our Eau de
integrator okay so I'm gonna walk you
through these lines are kind of where
all the magic happens I'm gonna walk you
through this so here what we have is
we're using OD E
and so we're integrating an odious
system of ordinary differential
equations in U hat so u hat is the state
vector and we're integrating that state
vector forward in time according to this
vector field in RHS heat the right hand
side of the heat equation and so that's
literally these terms right here are in
that function RHS heat and we define it
kind of in our in our notebook right
here ok and so RHS heat takes in a u hat
vector a time a Kappa and an alpha ok so
at an instant of time we take that state
vector u hat we multiply it by Kappa
squared by alpha squared and by minus 1
and so that's what you're gonna see here
is that we're we're taking our first
computing our derivative D u hat this is
the second derivative of U hat is minus
alpha squared times the second power of
Kappa so this Kappa very vector we're
squaring each element and we're
multiplying it by our u hat vector so
this is going to return a vector like
this
Kappa 1 squared u 1 hat Kappa 2 squared
u 2 hat and so on all of that times
minus alpha squared ok so my right hand
side function is literally just
computing this right-hand side of this
Oh de for every u hat given Kappa and
alpha and you know you can kind of work
through what the other lines are doing
they're just managing this the fact that
this is a complex a complex quantity
that we're integrating so now we we take
our our vector field and right hand side
heat we lock in the arguments Kappa and
alpha because this is only expecting the
right-hand side to be a function of time
and the state vector so we lock in Kappa
and alpha here then we give it our
initial condition and we give it our
vector of x that we want to integrate so
really all of the kind of guts of what's
happening computationally are happening
in this Oh de int line right here that
the whole system is being integrated in
that one line everything else was
initialization and then what we're going
to do is for each
for each of these you hats at each
instant and time we're gonna inverse
Fourier transform to get back the
original temperature in space at that
instant of time and then we're gonna
plot stuff so that's all that this is
doing is simulating and then plotting
and I like plotting this as a waterfall
that's kind of nice so here is a
waterfall plot showing this is our
spatial variable down here evolving in
time and the height of this is the
temperature distribution in space and in
time
okay so what you can see is that you
start off with this this rectangular
sharp square wave and then very very
rapidly the corners diffuse that's the
first thing that happens and then you
get this kind of larger diffusion and
eventually it turns into this nice
smooth Gaussian and if I simulated this
for longer that Gaussian would
eventually kind of start to spread out
over the whole domain until eventually
we were left with a constant okay that's
what we expect from the physics it's
nice that our FFT solution of this this
heat equation is consistent with what we
analytically know should be true in this
case you can also plot it essentially as
an image okay so we can also do em show
to just plot this so we have a function
U as a function of space and time so
that's kind of an array of temperatures
we can also plot it as an image and this
is what it looks like so here you can
see so kind of time is the vertical axis
space is the horizontal axis and you can
see that this thing starts off being
very sharp and rectangular and then it
smooths out as time evolves okay so it
kind of becomes more and more gradual
and smooth it's just another way of
plotting plotting this and I just want
to point out this is very consistent
with the physics of the problem okay so
what the physics is saying is that when
I Fourier transform the heat equation
the Fourier transform is actually an
eigenvector coordinate system so that's
also key is that these are eigenvectors
we're mapping into eigenvector
coordinates where now this system
becomes decoupled and diagonal for each
kappa i just have one ordinary
differential equation so i have n
decoupled oh des
and the particular lambda the eigenvalue
of that OD e is minus alpha squared
Kappa squared so for my low frequency
Fourier modes my low frequency sines and
cosines
that has a relatively slow decay
constant those are gonna stick around
for a long time but my higher and higher
frequency modes my really really high
frequency sines and cosines have then
Kappas really big and so this is a fast
decaying eigenvalue and so those high
wave numbers those high frequency sines
and cosines are gonna die out really
really quickly and that's exactly what
we see here corner sharp corners
generally have a lot of high frequency
Fourier content and very rapidly when
you run that through the heat equation
those sharp corners die out because they
have the largest decaying eigenvalues
okay so this is completely consistent
with the physics of the Fourier
transform being an eigenvector
coordinate where these are the
eigenvalues okay so that's kind of nice
okay so in this example what we have
seen is that you can Fourier transform
your PDE you can solve your whole
partial differential equation in the
Fourier domain you evolve it in time but
you evolve you hat instead of you and
that gets around computing all of these
derivatives you can instead just
simulate this simple decoupled OD II and
then when you're done with that you can
inverse Fourier transform and recover
your system in physical space okay so in
the next few lectures we're gonna solve
a couple of different PDE s we're gonna
solve the wave equation and the
nonlinear burgers equation and we'll see
how that looks okay thank you